[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero la
visita de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi el
pasado 3 de agosto a taiwán ha elevado
las tensiones entre esta isla y china a
unos niveles no vistos en décadas hasta
el punto de temer un nuevo conflicto
pero porque reclama china su soberanía
sobre taiwán en france24 lo repasamos
taiwán es una isla localizada en el
océano pacífico situada a tan solo unos
160 km de la china continental
históricamente ha albergado población
china y ha pertenecido a este país sin
embargo una serie de eventos bélicos que
marcaron a esta nación asiática durante
la primera mitad del siglo 20 hicieron
que se alejara del poder de beijing
hasta la actualidad para comprender su
particularidad política toca retroceder
hasta el año 1927 para esa época taiwán
llevaba más de 30 años bajo dominio
japonés y en la china continental se
empezó a librar una guerra por el poder
entre los nacionalistas del kuomintang
que dominaba en la política de la
república china desde 1912 y el recién
creado partido comunista un conflicto
que en un principio no afectó a taiwán
pero que con el tiempo sería fundamental
para entender la crisis actual
china no pudo recuperar su control hasta
1945 cuando los japoneses son derrotados
en la segunda guerra sino japonesa un
conflicto enmarcado dentro de la segunda
guerra mundial comunistas y
nacionalistas aparcaron durante un
tiempo sus diferencias para combatir al
invasor y enemigo común pero una vez las
fuerzas niponas fueron expulsadas la
guerra civil continuó con más dureza
los comunistas liderados por mao zhedong
multiplicaron su fortaleza durante la
guerra contra los japoneses gracias al
apoyo que consiguieron de la unión
soviética mientras que el kuomintang de
chiang kai-shek vio como su poder iba
colapsando en diferentes regiones de la
china continental
los nacionalistas recibieron el apoyo de
eeuu pero a partir de 1949 su situación
se volvió irreversible ante el avance de
las tropas de máó y chiang kai-shek se
vio obligado junto con más de un millón
y medio de soldados y miembros del
kuomintang a retirarse hacia la isla de
formosa actualmente conocida como taiwán
mao logró hacerse con todo el continente
pero no pudo asaltar la isla
eeuu fue firme a la hora de defender a
sus aliados del kuomintang y desplegó a
su armada en el estrecho de taiwán con
el objetivo de disuadir al precario
ejército comunista de mao el líder
comunista declaró la república popular
china y chiang kai-shek proclamó su
poder sobre la república china de taiwán
con él de volver algún día a retomar el
continente pero esto nunca sucedió
durante los primeros años la comunidad
internacional reconoció como la única
china a la basada en taiwán ya que para
eeuu o naciones unidas el gobierno de
mao en beijing era ilegítimo pero la
situación cambió radicalmente a finales
de la década de 1960 cuando eeuu y la
república popular china de mao
comenzaron a compartir adversario la
unión soviética y esto acercó los
intereses de beijing y washington un
contexto que favoreció que a partir de
octubre de 1971 naciones unidas-
reconociera únicamente como el
representante legítimo a la república
popular china y no a la república china
de chiang kai-shek y tan sólo ocho años
más tarde en 1979 e incluso eeuu
reconoció al gobierno de beijing como el
único válido tras casi 25 años basados
en taiwán nadie consideraba factible que
el kuomintang recuperará el poder en el
continente y a washington le interesaba
tener a la china comunista de su lado en
la guerra fría contra la
a partir de la década de 1970 cada vez
menos naciones del mundo reconocían a
taiwán como un estado y su presencia en
organizaciones internacionales como el
comité olímpico internacional o la o ms
fue desapareciendo sin embargo eeuu
continuó manteniendo una fuerte alianza
con taipei gracias a una estrecha
relación comercial y militar y advirtió
a la china comunista que cualquier
intento de invasión a taiwán supondría
un grave desafío a los intereses
estadounidenses aunque beijing nunca
ocultó su intención de recuperar la isla
nos oponemos firmemente a cualquier
diseño para separar a taiwán de la
patria el pueblo chino está decidido a
liberar a taiwán y ninguna fuerza puede
detenernos frank twist en los años 80
beijing intentó incluir a taiwán en el
modelo de un país dos sistemas que han
aplicado en algún momento en hong kong y
macao pero el gobierno taiwanés lo
rechazó además el sentimiento de muchos
ciudadanos de la isla ha cambiado a
pesar de que el territorio se sigue
denominando como república china
importante de personas no se consideran
chinas sino taiwanesas y el sentimiento
de autodeterminación ha aumentado algo
que desde beijing no se quiere tolerar
ya que se considera a taiwán como una
provincia rebelde y un asunto interno
que se debe solucionar el gobierno de xi
jinping ha expresado que actuara con
contundencia ante cualquier intento de
secesión y condena que actos como la
visita de pelosi a taiwán son
injerencias extranjeras para estados
unidos sin embargo taiwán es una pieza
fundamental en el sistema de contención
al poder de influencia chino la duda
ahora está en si washington estaría
dispuesto a actuar ante una hipotética
intervención china en taiwán alegando
que es una invasión
especialmente cuando la mayoría del
planeta incluido ellos no reconocen a
este territorio como una nación un punto
que hace que taiwán carezca de derechos
internacionales
con esto concluimos gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 puntos
[Música]